catch up one or two it went so well last
time
that we're gonna do another one I went
to run to anyone who's considering going
and hasn't been it's [ __ ] mint you
domini bum howdy
[Laughter]
good question Christmas was honestly
autistic I can't believe you're a train
no and then he says your mate your
business partner the guy with the beard
I was trying I was putting a leaflet
promotionally for his door and he you
sat in the window and he got up and he
banged on the window I'm like what you
doing mate this actually happened yeah
so though the reason that this has
occurred is because on your letterbox
you have a statement no junk mail the
guys reply was he shouldn't live in a
shooting area it wouldn't happen
that's that's equivalent to she
shouldn't have been wearing that ladies
and gentlemen welcome back Johnny and
Youssef from propane fitness comm are
here again catch up one or two it went
so well last time that we're gonna do
another one just talking about whatever
the house you have whatever the whatever
the [ __ ] is going on
catch you down the first thing the first
thing which is going on is for the
listeners at home who aren't watching on
YouTube you are missing out my belated
birthday present is adorned across my
chest and it worries this lovely soaring
t-shirt you like the Sun behind us of
plate plane because it's a plane soaring
you think the chocolate one banana
though it's a same color look it's not
though it's the same kidding you so
varis that is this plane serene for
anyone that doesn't understand this
Chris's idea of a pre-meal snack he is
an entire soaring Malo
extremely dense
like a the closest thing in food terms
to a brick and a kilo yogurt you need to
have a lot of compression TVs to wait
for them to air when you rate and then
you know they get so weatherproof don't
like it would stand all that means it's
a cake not a biscuit okay kids get to go
to the park just so that there's a story
that every forensic accountant loves to
tell because it's the only jaffa cakes
yeah yeah can you relay that oh god I'll
probably get it wrong so you charge VAT
on biscuits but not cakes because
biscuits are seen as a luxury item cakes
aren't because birthday cakes a
necessity I think because case used to
be made from leftover necessity foods
okay whereas biscuits aren't I think
this is right I'm so sorry if it's wrong
this is just some like an artifact of a
time gone by that's just the way that
the fries are classified biscuits cakes
are as boys are gonna be like do not so
jaffa cakes were like like we're wear a
cape mate like don't we don't pay v18
welcome me here and then they were
subject to the biscuit cake test which
was the biscuits go soft soft when left
today were still hot what do they do
they go hard so if you can develop a
biscuit that goes hard well yeah I'm
gonna biscuit know if he can develop a
biscuit which gets harder well then
you've Rudy what you gotta hit Chris
he's a cake Oh
but by that by that logic if you can
have something which has the texture of
a biscuit mmm but then goes you you have
essentially okay a cake masquerading as
biscuit well this is why jaffa cakes
allow themselves to be to evade the need
to be taxable I just found a tiny bit of
my birthday cake on my nose now onion
onion upon my know if you must have got
a saw that no one decided sorry mother
didn't your
but that banter great your brother did
he try ask for a bit of pizza heated up
in correct oh yeah eat it up because
right it's laughable so oh wow
so I remember we're not we're not sure
of the reason I'm guessing mas anything
smart Amalia I was dragging my brother
to the gym and not sometimes I have to
take care of him you know he's he's only
44 so so I was like right before we go
to the gym are you hungry
he's off starving my okay let's let's
just pull into the Greg's went in and he
was like and this is this is him having
a real problem because he's he's
wrestling with the moralistic attempt to
try and be Hollow and the fact that he
was surrounded by sausage it surrounded
by such a service so I was like look you
should get the steak and cheese roll it
seems like I'm like you're trying to be
halal on you and he was like yeah if I
can't this is where you say hello it's
like a French person saying croissant
the croizon
hello hello hello no I'm still
anglicized a bit anyway Chris and I
should try learning to try and correctly
pronounce your shut up Afghanistan
tougher anyway sorry so he was like okay
can I have one of those veg retro thing
there veg pastries and they were like oh
I haven't got any left
okay can I have the four cheese pizza no
there isn't any okay can I have that bit
of pizza but can have a hot no wait but
we kind of heat them up I was like well
why not cake it is it hot
no but can you just can you not heat it
up I was like the steak cheese rolls are
hard
[Laughter]
is that look can you just get this at
NOAA's health and safety and exact look
I don't care about health and safety
can you just heater I just want to have
a hot bit of pizza and then oh right
give me a toffee yum yum and chocolate
eclairs yeah so it's like tap mission
tax evasion road tax avoidance okay okay
okay sausage once once was in the farm
with a pig but isn't a pit finally Haram
just a forbidden forbidden event ones in
Germany mr. button you are forbidden
pork is bad so he's he's then in the car
stuffing in three creamy chocolatey
treats that he really didn't want
because their fifth choice done because
he discovered himself into having
basically I'm hungry but I have three
constraints I want it to be from Gregg's
hot and be club and that bit of pizza
the same great party has this like cuz
it's on quite rough streets on shields
Road apparently there's a guy that comes
in and just Nick's stuff and quite often
he'll come in this was Alec so he was
saying that um he was in there in the
queue and this guy ran in and took a
tray of pastries and just ran out and
all the staff just went nuts like as if
like are not gone he's like this is a
frequent occurrence you know they need
security
yeah but then
is it worth the paying the security man
you know or a security guys how are you
total cost of production of that range
range of like four by six because Haiti
pH were partly so yeah even if it's 20
RP can we talk about the time when can I
tell my story
oh yes that's a great story yes okay so
today or a while ago in podcast land
yeah I was walking from my car to cost a
coffee I wouldn't say we're in case
anyone tries to follow me but somewhere
in New Castle and as I'm walking this
can kind of give it away a little bit
someone can pass an easy shot ephone
shock right i standing at the door the
phone shop is a fairly well muscled man
looking frustrated because he isn't open
yet right so i notice this air pods in
actually listening to catch up one at
once this is a very method of here
and I saw him see me and then just like
missile lock onto me and follow me along
and I noticed he like exciting him okay
as I dive again he's still doing it
mm-hmm because I didn't get started on a
petrol station that time November so I'm
just always you know whenever I'm around
cars then see him turn around and run
back towards a white van like okay
mm-hmm walk into Koster ordering my
decaf of course coffee see him then run
back towards Koster come into Koster and
as he comes around the door I noticed
he's got a handful of protein bars I'm
like okay he's got a t-shirt that says
ot on it
like if this guys coming in fact me this
is a very convoluted way of attacking
someone so he's like hi mate listen to
the podcasts etc all that all these nice
things say hello familiar with rape
modern wisdom etc got talking about the
protein bars that he was giving me to
try and things like this
and then he said um actually you're your
mate your business partner the guy with
the beard
I was trying I was putting a leaflet
promotionally for his door and he you
sat in the window and he got up and he
banged on the window
I'm like what you doing so quite often
people bring their dog into into the
little bit for my front door bar you
know really a dog I'm not like proving
their dog yeah it's like because even if
they pick it up this long it's residual
Floyd - yeah so I just loved I loved how
long when did that experience was for me
for a scary problem to happen yeah so
the reason that this has occurred is
because on your letterbox you have a
statement no junk mail the guys reply
was he shouldn't live in a shooting area
it wouldn't happen that's that's
equivalent to she shouldn't have been
wearing that encouraging culture and I
think I'll say reprehensible not really
thank you for the attempt of the Oh team
bar sorry for any offence of course and
so he what so actually he then went on
to say that part of the reason why he
now has a bar based strategy rather
floor is a much better strategy piece of
experience it's like mate if you had a
bar and you approach the door bar of a
bar then you're gonna hide open arms up
you even have to an asterisk now it's
like accept free gifts no junk mail
items of value are accepted
yet minimum minimum cash value equals 25
pence or above so you innocent accept
anything with a cash value wouldn't know
because just PayPal cash money yeah and
then you end up with a bunch of what
about anything that we searched buys you
over quit cuz the ball lake of trying to
find a market liquidity for that and
services is a problem what what I love
about your story is the instant frame
shift from threat big dude locking onto
me mm-hm to put protein bar in his hand
same situation and it's suddenly our
great body pop if you hadn't been
wearing the t-shirt as well
mmm yeah cuz pretty bad like maybe you
need to amid beat up Johnny snack oh yes
so I mean got energized man he's he's
not he's been fueled with his own
Islamic are telling collagen yeah um I
thought that your initial concern was
gonna be that you might be abducted and
put into the white van but I challenge
anyone out there to move you to anywhere
that you don't want to be because you
actually otherwise starts yeah there's
just nothing job racist I think about it
like if I was just lay there and he
tried to make me but I think if I if I'm
trying to stop him from leaving me it's
this it's certainly not gonna be easy
for him
no no cuz I'm not my coffee I either I'd
ordered the coffee a paid for coffee I
hadn't had it yet oh he tries to take me
where though did he give you a no team
bar in a coffee shop that sells
essentially all team bars like
flapjacked yeah and the the woman was
also like trying to complete the
transaction with me I was dealing with
mr. ot mediating I mean he's a nice guy
nice to me to give her stuff for this
instance podcast probably listen to this
fantastic shower so yeah give us some
optimism one day so II wanted you two to
promise that I didn't know what your
affiliations were ya said I don't get
involved in the problem the problem is
that anyone who's had a no team bar
knows why they're doing this much promo
so you just like ante promo that sorry
partner well look I'm just so I actually
and I'm not I promise I'm not affiliated
in any way I was actually quite
impressed okay
I had a brownie and a
protein bar um I was I was quite
impressed might have tried the but
everyone Whitley Bay they I've never had
them can't comment but there might be
our honor that yeah if the pig flavor
look at me Pig flavor that's okay
dust your smoky bacon flavor crisps a
Toby haha but she's an onion apparently
enough why well then it move it needs to
be they used animal rennet in them run
it like the the scooping from the
stomach of an animal ever counts hang on
so scooping but in the towers at the
calzone II isn't grass yeah the grass is
fine that's happen so hydrolyzed whey I
mean your car is totally natural because
the the oil the petrol is from the oil
rocks and three countries this it's all
so the hippies were also the the the
rennet mmm-hmm is not collude okay
because the cows not hello
yeah the cows alive well they have to
kill the cow to get the rest of a yeah
like an ice cream so if it was a halal
cow down cut through cut his throat then
ready yeah then you get the rennet
fantastic I went to wrong yeah you
didn't look very good when in room I
didn't do it once
I didn't even while he was there make
sure you use the fridge came for me
opportunity when in Rome Denis would
would would you accompany have
understood the reference and then it's
not really complex reference I suddenly
I suddenly people oh I know it's not we
don't understand the reference
yeah they only have when in Reykjavik
when eating crop yeah exactly was having
skin
ah can I believe can we can we please
just divert for a second to work out how
the [ __ ] company managed to own the
word skier in the UK it's amazing Arlo
Allah o Allah own skier and it's [ __ ]
compared to actual skier from us how
animated I got about anyone who doesn't
know what skier is it it's like very
thick yogurt and he's good Christmas
more than that it is more than yogurt uh
I've done it the service I apologize but
yeah I went to wrong and to anyone who's
considering going and hasn't been it's
[ __ ] mint mush so good like just
sensory overload couldn't there was I
don't have enough mental run to be able
to take in all of the stuff that was
going on I'll sense video guardian some
foes so that you can see some of the
cool [ __ ] I saw did you have a
cappuccino I had [ __ ] loads of coffee
we were up better than you better than
you thought same as so had this was this
is a bad bit of the experience so I
decided that I was gonna go like as
phone free as possible for the entirety
the trip so thumb didn't go out with me
on any of the the trips other people had
like recording [ __ ] and then yeah left
my phone home and I decided well when I
got off the train that I was going to
find my way to the hotel like old-school
style I was the first one to get to the
hotel so didn't know I was like oh I can
take as long as I want what the wrong
direction immediately straight out the
train station we got off on the wrong
side of the platform walk the wrong way
no it's bad start and then I was like
little bit tired early flight so I could
get myself an espresso and I'm just like
totally blown away by these high
Stonestreet old old it like it's hot
more than I tell you this thing comes to
this next bit so all of this coffee
going to go into this little cafe bar
think pretty cool order espresso one
euro
well one Europe for an espresso so like
what 85 people do something like that I
was like I am gonna really enjoy here 85
feet for an espresso and I'm just
looking out the window so I can see as
the top of
Peter's Basilica the Sistine Chapel and
all that sort of bollocks of the far
side and I've put small amount of sugar
in just a sweetener I don't just like
stirring as I'm looking at the window
staring stir any way still staring
looking out the window look back down
and I have managed to get all of the
espresso out and or matter the counter I
just on top of the counter it's on some
of the sandwiches that were behind the
counter it's on the front of the the
slanted front of the glass counter now
dribbling down towards my owner who was
over the far side and the they were just
looking at me me that as I was doing
this I was just sloshing the most aghast
[Music]
actually just put his head in his hand
and just went like oh that's Italian
Fury is no he's gonna course and then I
saw a man a song so it's about 2:30 in
the afternoon
so a man come in order a large glass of
red wine say grazie to the people that
were in there down it woke up so you
Italians what [ __ ] was it minutes
this during the week on a Thursday
Thursday excellent to me after we should
leave in the wrong place like we just
live in the wrong countries that what it
is oh did we talked about this last time
were you walking on like a Marks &
Spencer on a Tuesday morning and like
there's loads of people that yeah so I
think if you walk into a whatever the
equivalent is in Rome everyone's just
swashy limpin eeny zillion night yeah so
a but it was just a street lots of a
street says it's the big the three-piece
big big three peas pizza pasta pastries
like the penis no pain in the penis mapu
no neither thankfully although there may
be need to do a stool sample no but like
the one thing that I wasn't aware of
like prepared for was the assault of
gluten is unrelenting everything is
carbs like you think that you're
actually having check
but it's just like chicken shape though
if I make it nicer by just putting fat
and garlic everything early
it's bread fat and garlic that's just
Italy we went to a place coffee went to
a place near Sorrento down on the Amalfi
Coast just down from Pompeii which is a
Sunday beautiful drive and went to a
pizzeria where you buy pizza by the
meter oh my god those places are legit
so they bring in what we're know so it's
what I can only describe as a song as a
sweatshirt yeah so this guy has a three
meter long flat bit of wood some guy
feeds it in from behind him there's all
scaffolding if you can imagine it's like
clumping down and the scaffolding in to
get slid towards him and then he gets
like some of that the flower throws it
on rubs it in get some of the dome like
whizzes it round clocks it on and then
just two segments where one flavor of
the pizza finishes and another one
begins it just adds some more dough
rolls up some dough strings it on like
creates a little barrier little bread
barrier and then throws some toppings on
that bit some toppings on that bit hides
it in the oven then it comes out and if
you're eating from end to end you and
the other person have to shout to speak
to each other because you're [ __ ]
miles apart
Wow but that money it was like
unbelievable like very very impressive
place and nine euros for pizza and ten
euros for pasta so I five went to room 8
two years ago and Venice a year ago Rome
brilliant Venice just tourism this is
quite dirty yeah really disappointing
bonus I thought I wanna go I want to go
to Florence with my mom later this year
that's like the other big hour there
aren't that like 10 years ago a long
time ago so that's nice look it is nice
you don't need one handy no someone
suggested was it the most
Johnny's good it's like you worry about
question Christmas was honestly autistic
I can't believe you're a brilliant yes
so me and Daniel sloths were talking
about our individual strategies for how
we had shave down there okay and we came
up with the shame squat which is pretty
correct also a biomechanically very good
position to poo in as well mmm that well
of kinking I was thinking I reckon
rectum hundred percent this is it this
is there's a product called the squatty
potty just which yeah if you if you
struggle with poos you can buy it it's
fits in a u-shape around your toilet and
your basically allows you to sit in a
squat position what's different what is
the difference between that and what
five-year-olds use to help them reach
the toilet oh it's the same but because
five you buy one of that but because
five-year-olds have this smaller their
hips are in each more extension need to
be in front of you right you couldn't be
now my point is that a five-year-old
steps up to we forward but so that's
just a little step in front of toilet
okay yes
ring so you need to be able to go now
they need to be able to squat it's a
pregnancy pillow but around the toilet
ya need to build squat needs to be able
do that it may be even use the pregnancy
pillow to double up wouldn't recommend
it I'm gonna I'm gonna talk about my
upgraded pregnancy pillow yeah and yet
so Daniel floss episode James co-op
shaving bumhole nether regions how do I
know you ain't gonna forget me but now
you talking about Lisa Lisa by the meter
and then suddenly I've got a trajectory
it although it still what hold on power
on the mean I have a methyl it for years
no but like recently how long has it
been very 300 Keeley
for days so it's timely this is a timely
topic yeah do you do with there is wait
wait you jumping
stop it stop it be ruining it means a
nice loss shame squat we said that you
have to work yourself up because anyone
who's ever used an electric razor like
even a normal no more electric rates
down there is like your scrotum is it's
corrugated frequently it's it's the fact
that it's crinkly mmm like it's just
built to get nicked by stuff yeah and
[ __ ] like it's so painful and when it
happens and what do you do do you stop
do you keep going you're like often half
of it look like a Alan Shearer before he
accepted that he was going bowling
[Music]
Alan met honestly what's this the island
doesn't ring yeah but just like and so
do you so we posted it I've talked about
this online someone tweeted me and said
so Daniel you just shave Daniel just
shave same as same as me and squat and
someone tweeted and said app Daniel I
Kris gives a both amateurs feet
sensitive hair removal cream I mentioned
it once to Yousuf we went to the sauna
on Sunday and he said yeah
so next Asda order online fully
recommended never go back to a
supermarket again never have to buy the
beat sensitive in front of other people
just talk about it online all of those
people have free unlimited access to it
yeah but I would highly recommend for
anyone for health hygiene speed if
you're a you know speed swimmer speed
runner
I avoid the aerodynamic in the ends
exactly just Oh Erica and just general
quality of life no but it was it was
there any how's the discomfort because
there's a tiny enough none whatsoever so
imagine it pins that's it as yeah I
think it's important to get the feet
sensitive I've not tried the feet normal
so I can't be broke
yeah but last time we were talking about
this dream and about the original okay I
actually quite like the Listerine that
makes me go like
I don't think the mccune same can be
said for being woken up by bum-rush yeah
well that I mean that as they say on the
packet you should test on a innocuous
bit of skin first make sure there's no
allergy make sure there's no what we
cannot do is for the skin you choke I
didn't because I've used other of his
previous hardcore V before so that's
true but you're right like I could have
changed the formula y 100 genic I think
probably project Ares is perfumed and so
if you don't know what we're talking
about read a recent article on propane
about BPA in Eastridge ins in the
environment terrifying article basically
we're being poisoned left right and
center well I mean you you would never
mean feet would you because you are
completely hairless hello the bottom
left from the bottom lip yeah yeah I am
I think fortunate I mean credit don't
know much tonight like I'm Julia you're
very hairy honey
yeah but not other an Arab in my family
I'm the least Harriet my brother you
know the horrible bits of hair that you
get like come into answer yeah hit
that's just continuous with his buck and
then he's in Greg's and the guy and Greg
is like YV you are such a hairy back and
right look he's our committee the pizza
yeah yeah man so and what we've been
watching on Netflix recently we start
talking about that I watched [ __ ] you
[ __ ] Serbian and watched anything
well that was yeah it was it was back
when we've done them all right okay
Indians were in the magical times yeah
yeah and yes a flat earther believe the
dome or something leave the dome I was
keen to become the flower but I was like
look I'm really willing something sort
of thing you would believe it like
Socratic ly I'm ready to like actin peel
apart all of my beliefs and be like
right is there a convincing argument but
the problem is it's like her it's like
you don't whether like when or where in
your life are you a flat earther the
first thing I thought of was your
every every week for 12 weeks really if
anything more extreme I'm going under
the water for an hour lower these things
so what but the problem is so the
difference is I am an evidence-based
person and so in when there is evidence
to Pro or contrary to to a belief I will
adjust by Hubley shift on the time these
flat earth has shift on a dime to twist
reality too much than you know and
there's a really really interesting clip
from it I think you were both both seen
where they they do this special test
where they shine a pinhole of light
through a sheet with a hole in and then
300 meters away they have another guy
receiving the light and based on the
angle that determines whether if they
can if the earth was flat they would be
able to see it at the horizontal angle
and if it's not it would go up slightly
and so they tested it and it showed that
the earth was curved or it showed a
curvature it showed a curvature if the
well he had to raise it didn't it you
have to raise it raise it to account for
the fact that the earth is good for the
sort of calculate the curvature and so
then they were like oh no but that's
just because there's there's heavenly
energies that are shifting the light
causing this and what we need to do is
we need we need to repeat this in a
Gaussian chamber and so they're then
repeated it the skylight drops 26 grand
to get a Gaussian chamber and they
repeated the experiment same thing
happening and they were like oh but
that's because there's a refraction
reinfect from the magnetic field and
that's cause there's a really good buy
isn't it like oh is it the 26 grand by
the extra risk oh yeah yeah right
and he says one of the guys is literally
saying this could really throw it puzzle
in the works here it's like you are not
trying to find out the truth you are
trying to find things which support your
observation bias that's just it's the
whole thing's confirmation but like well
that this better not get out to the
flowers crowd if if it does show up that
whole documentaries of it it's funny but
it would make me more annoyed if they
were less ridiculous
yeah the two questions that I would have
for them is firstly what did they think
why do they think the lies being
protected so aggressively by big fast
such a pointless Lyle I say whose views
gaining Satan CIA division the CIA's
near like he was he was gaining from the
fact that we think the word there is a
sphere yeah
whereas they are gaining financially in
many ways from saying that the earth is
flat the podcast of the where's where's
the all teary alternative motive and
secondly like save that 26 grand and
just [ __ ] find the edge of it did you
see take a photo of the edge of it to be
seen Alex Jones on girag no the second
one so anyone who is listening hasn't
seen this the man is a force of nature
so he him and Joe Rogan had a pretty
public fallout recently and he basically
called for the destruction of Jerome but
use this you know do you know how means
you know yeah you know he's like the
David Icke successor in a way kind of
he's like a right with a right-leaning
American political commentator who's
been deep platform from a few different
laces go round-faced America they're
making the frogs gay yet very shocked he
says psychotic things like that I really
like talks about everyone like the big
politicians being lizards and okay but
the the thing about Alex Jones that
makes him so compelling is that he is
such an unbelievable speaker like
I couldn't should go on admire him in a
really bizarre fashion because his
capacity to just elucidate everything so
you hear him speak and he's he'll be
talking about the CIA and the moon
landings and of course this is why it
happened and you know that dogs are
psychic buffers yeah dogs can be psychic
buffers they kind of take in auras a
little bit like the aliens do but not
the real aliens because the real aliens
are the ones they're connecting like
intravenously with everybody like the
greys the graves the greys are simply
just like artificial intelligent and you
like
there's so many so many vast concepts is
connected and he just doesn't enjoy the
way yeah
Joe is like trying desperately if
there's anyone in the world that can
wrangle a conversation like that it's
Joe Rogan yeah and he is it's like being
precious sprayed you just [ __ ]
[ __ ] at all time but he talked about
um he was like I will give a million
pounds it was like I'm not a rich man
and I've got a million pounds it's like
I would give him a million pounds to
someone to charter a flight to fly over
the Antarctic and he wants Eddie Bravo
to do it
he was like Eddie to find the edge of
the earth yes see if we confront because
that's why they say it is right to do it
so you know how we we see the North Pole
as a point where as I guess they see it
is like all the edge all the way around
so it's just all pole so it's nice for
the guy outside applause they got
another guy mark Sargent and the
documentary said that he tracked flights
and no flight flew over a portion of the
ocean and then someone's about let me in
sighs I don't know but is that flight
come from and what's that one going but
then he would say oh the site's fake
like vomit because challenge it yeah
there's always Big Pharma to blame if
you need anyone to blame it's no but
yeah it's just this guy who owns a farm
that's massive like he's already have
you seen the most recent Amazon Prime
documentary which is about Big Pharma
and the effect of antipsychotic drugs on
kids
no so there is some really [ __ ]
harrowing research about the I think
it's a top ten antidepressants and the
fact that pretty much every mass
shooting in America the people that
perpetrators have had one or more of
these drugs in them and they wouldn't
release the toxicology report of the
other person from what was the really
famous one others to the guys
the ben shapiro called out piers morgan
for singing oh yeah
sang sandy is sunny oh they wouldn't
release the toxicology report of the
second because the first one came up
that he had like x in his system and
they were pretty certain that the second
one and if you had this big school
shooting and both of the the common
denominator denominator between the two
wasn't that they both had like a
previous history of mental illness it
was fact they were both on these
anti-psychotic drugs surely there are
lots of other commonalities like it
because in that case it's hard to say
whether it's causation or correlation
they are but the it was just something
that Big Pharma wanted to eat that
that's why they're literally not
allowing them the Americans are so bad
they love over medicating kids with just
it so there was a I remember so my dad
was a psychiatrist and I remember
showing him a bit of the Louis Theroux
documentary whatever medicated kids and
there's a ten-year-old boy he's 11 now
that had five diagnoses he had a
diagnosis of I'm seeing that yeah OCD
bipolar disorder schizophrenia autism
and ADHD and he was on five separate
medications for each of these conditions
the family were all on something feeding
the dog for PTSD apparently what don't
come through work the eggs I said that
that's another it's another flag on like
the family just think with the [ __ ] yeah
maybe let's just throw medications at it
and I remember my dad watching in being
like first of all statistically the
likelihood of all of these conditions to
be you know one in a thousand so that
all of these simultaneously plus this
one is a chemical imbalance in this way
and this one is in the opposite way it
is impossible to have both
simultaneously and these drugs have not
been tested on people under 18 years old
so no no this is abusive
but so what you've got is just like this
idea that we should just throw drugs at
people it's but untested on most age
range I'll never and it's only um of
course America and Australia that are
advertised they're allowed to advertise
drug and the others are like hey do you
wake up in the morning and feel a bit
groggy and then do you go to bed at
night and do you sometimes feel hungry
and do you it sucks it's not turning me
percocet yeah it seemed from Chris Rock
stand up isn't it where he goes like
they just keep on naming symptoms until
they come up with one that you've got
nausea headache yeah he says like are
you tired d feet hurt are you bald what
have you got he uses some language that
I'm not going to try and use because
that would get me in trouble but yeah
and he just keeps on naming things if
you want to watch an awesome documentary
prescription thugs by Chris Bell who is
the guy that also made bigger stronger
faster and that is so harrowing from fan
tastic and he like even on that he was
taking them and lying to the people that
he was producing the show for that he
wasn't on them while he was on them
while he was doing a show about not
being on them and they're like oh this
is pervasive as [ __ ] Wow so it makes me
so glad they're in the UK I think
because it's the it's not the drugs
themselves but it's the use of them it's
like having such a low threshold for
like how people don't appreciate it
because it's just a pillow fine like you
know but because you know you take your
party smaller and there's no this is my
visible effect yeah so I was trying to
find a horrid image on social media
today which was like I take this drug to
deal with this side effect and I take
this one to deal with this that I get
from taking this you know blah blah blah
because like diet training and sleep and
lifestyle management is just too much
hassle or something like that but it's I
suppose the because it's branded and
because it's solution-based the problems
that people are experiencing it's not
like let's just think it's my money
we're all there for drugs here
easiest fix isn't it even I remember
being in Vegas in a pool shafted but you
know you're like hungover dehydrated you
you're in the desert you're jet-lagged
oh hang on I want like you're in a
pooling babe no that's great we're
speaking to this this group of girls
where he were from like I don't know
somewhere in America but it still had a
long flight like two or three hours or
something no you know boo-boo and I was
like yeah I really struggle to get to
sleep on planes and like what do you
mean I was like I really struggle to get
to support planes and their answers just
xanax and it's not quite the same
yeah but what is Amex again I imagine
it's a brand a drug that's also known in
the UK and I think it's diazepam
it's an American trade name but what
solid state snake takes it just like
please look if some of you take too many
than eight like he gives do you drop his
health or something yeah and it's just
that let's look it up the first the
first port of call it would appear for a
lot of Americans just medicate yeah yeah
and I was thinking about this earlier on
so in lifehacks one a sudden we talked
about Pomodoro Technique and I'm
currently reading deep work which I'll
be done on soon and we're going to start
doing essentially a modern wisdom
booklet which is where we'll review
books that we've read and then deliver
some like key readings and stuff like
that so if there are any books that you
want us to cover or the you've read that
we think that we should drop it in the
comments below um but I part way through
it like 50 pages in the deep work and
it's just delivering some real home
truths to me okay I really I don't want
to swallow wait till you read and then
of us struggles well I've listened to
the insisting three of you yeah it'll be
it you know what works being punched in
the gut
yeah Digital Menem isn't someone just
going with like sharp things at your
eyes hazel is it much worse I thought
it's just right but for both of them I
just like
you [ __ ] so I'm like you've been fully
subbed in dears and they know what you
know I started thinking about with that
is the equivalent situation that appears
to be occurring in so many different
areas of life same in training and
wanting to get lean and the same in
working and the same in dealing with
emotions or feeling feelings feeling
feelings these feelings are
uncomfortable I'm gonna medicate my way
out of it it's I'm not being productive
enough and as opposed to let's spend
some time doing some introspective work
actually work out what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me or why I feel this way etcetera
etcetera
doop do the work I'm not being
productive enough therefore I'm gonna
take some nootropics which of these
wouldn't proven like untested drugs and
just throw them in me and see what
happened more I'm gonna fill this all
full of lots of caffeine or I'm going to
work for inordinate amounts of time to
get an amount of work done that could
have been achieved in five hours yeah
instead of actually tackling the issue
which is I do low concentration diffuse
work across a lot of different tasks and
don't actually do along what you can
tell I'm taking it it's such a high
yield thing to fix before we start in
the tropics and they're like yeah it's
like the guy who doesn't train doesn't
sleep doesn't need sufficient staff
Alfred
this is where my effect efficiency exam
by today it felt like pouring fuel on a
fire that's barely burning so the the
Tiago Forte's productivity pyramid
really slots into place yeah because
it's like that's just computer literacy
but it's only part of the pyramid and
it's like saying you know it calories in
place but you it's all from cake and
it's like a piece of meat to fix that
where's doing something fast but if
you're doing something inefficient yeah
an effective fast is still is in effect
he's going quicker in the wrong
direction
yeah slow still moving slowly but tell
you what one of the one of the quotes
from James clears
atomic habit such a really [ __ ] love
and I never thought of before was where
he says he's talking about people who
are working hard and working effective
haven't achieved their goals yet and a
feeling dissatisfied and he said being
in the correct trajectory and being
concerned about not getting about not
being there yet is the same as getting
in your car to drive to a destination
and complaining that you haven't arrived
yeah like you're going in the right
direction
nothing yeah there is nothing to do then
just continue to make the car go in the
direction it's going in so I I digitally
minimally tweeted about this today did
you Alfred it no didn't tweet for my
wife tweet Alfred citizen seems to see
they press command let's return okay if
you press return it deletes if you press
command return it tweet it there's a
healthy skepticism there once did you
notice that I am tweeting to prove Yusef
wrong command return fine and then do
they come up with okay so yeah anyway
three today just saying a quote from one
of our articles the bad news is there's
no way to accelerate the process the
good news is there's no way to
accelerate the process and it's actually
so liberating when you fully get that
because it's like I just love you I
still have an anxiety there because but
how do we get faster worry that's it
cancels it or not because they're not
there yet they think well I'm in the
wrong direction don't they yeah it's
like I should be there I'm not there
maybe the process is wrong the open look
didn't ya die is the I thinks it what
all these books are making me realize is
that I actually haven't got a clue how
to just manage myself I it's so
frustrating after all the years of yeah
because but each book just points out a
bit Li's you idiot there and that and
yellow are yeah yeah deep deep work
atomic cupboards digital mentalism
probably left so I digital MLM ISM is
like these are the two things you need
to do and this and digital ISM minimum
ISM minimalism is just dealing with the
[ __ ] get some stomachs away
I'm reading the life-changing art of not
giving a [ __ ] no no he's just releasing
you book actually my Monson the
life-changing magic of tidying up or
something by a recon Connor a condo but
inky okay but to be honest it's it's a
similar approach towards personal
organization view physical spaces and
again you just realize you she makes
point in the book of like no one ever
teaches you how to organize effectively
organize your spaces well I get some
Harris [ __ ] hit the nail on the head
as much as people might not like he's a
little bit out there in a kind of a bit
of a wonky intellectual firm probably a
lawsuit so it speaks like a written
essay all super slowly and full prose
hmm but he hits now in the head and
saves earn much of our lives are taken
up learning how to live once we find an
approximation of it we stick at that for
the rest of our days I mean like [ __ ]
yeah you are right like I just work out
some approximation of how I live
effectively say that'll do and then
double down on it for the rest of time
and that's what we should do no no
that's what people do do rather than
optimizing to by all times I think is
it's easy also there to get stuck in
constantly optimizing and never actually
doing anything well that's the
difference between being on receive and
being on send right it's mindless
accumulation I've I struggle with this
like I've just I just mindlessly index
reams of data and stuff and then it's
like well hang on I haven't actually
implemented any of this and I think
Johnny started to do the opposite really
effectively after carrot jy instantly
which was just you read a book and
rather than read it from cover to cover
every time you come across they're like
are you then stop reflect on it do the
thing and then teach it to someone else
well I create a bit of content about it
and then you've just solidified or just
cemented a word were to do it although
if you're reading a book
that like atomic habits it would take
you a year to finish because this every
age is actionable so I've had a fair to
say encounter approach to that which is
that like if you're reading the right
things the things that you think will
stick that's tip Ferris right yeah so
good [ __ ] sticks I don't know who you
are just in time so that's yeah it's not
like I say this just in time there right
it's that it's more like you will you
will take your own top filtering the
best things to naturally but anything is
thus an argument to keep rereading books
because at different stages of your life
if you look as well yeah I think if
you're reading to solve problem or
improve your specific thing like if
you're looking for an outcome from a
book rather than just reading you'll
you're likely looking for the answer so
when you find it or you're looking for
the insights when you find it you
remember it so definitely the stuff that
I'm like it happens especially with it a
course or so like we saw with digital
minimalism what I was looking for for
that was like how can I just improve my
relationship with technology so you're
most looking for what I can model - yeah
rest you attention on whereas if you're
just reading a book cuz he might find it
interesting
yeah you just they just kind of all goes
I mean how much how much
self-development to people read from
that sphere of books
where they're reading for pleasure like
I think people read because they
someone's told him to read it or even
that even if someone's told them to read
it it's that this will benefit my life
this will make my life better somehow so
there is a frame this is being draped
over it's easy to read that stuff for
pleasure though if it's like if it
replaces if it acts as a surrogate for
the oh I'm moving forward because I'm
reading a book about the worst pro
stages is having some really
well-written notes on deep work while
still working shallowly and having some
really well-written notes on the topic
of it well not actually having any
consistent habits yeah yeah well
actually I don't mean belly just not
doing any of that and then I wouldn't
feel bad about not doing it yeah it's
the second order a second order effect
I'm knowing knowing that you know
it and still not doing the second arrow
speaking of optimizing you've you've
overheard the Serge [ __ ] interview no
I read his medium an article which was
45 minutes long okay yeah similar thing
he's a guy who's he's like a Silicon
Valley tech guy has just decided to turn
himself into an experiment and he's just
nailing all of the nootropics and
testosterone like a load of mercury and
lithium yeah yeah no does lithium Louis
the Tala prom Santi depressant clomid
put the theme like microsourcing MDMA
yeah MDMA just basically you know some
of these things almost constant each
other out probably yeah he basically
just says like if I just try all of them
and then something like he's like I
think the net benefit that I get
eventually will he was tracking he's
been tracking it a fair bit so he's like
the ultimate Bayaka
where at me a fair bit and having his
blood stones and stuff it's just not
very it's not very scientific way to
approach problems it
it's an osteon t because if he feels
better great but like do i have to live
this way for the rest of my life all
things I think that's his intention he
says oh he wants his shotgun human and
try and like really elongate his life me
you know he's like I'm happy to be at
the forefront of this but I suppose in
his case like he's got a lot of quite
interesting like he he goes and there's
like a agency where he pays Russian
models to sleep with yeah
very open about his transactional sex
life because he says like it's just he
wants to have no you must have no shame
about anything so it's like including
sexual proclivities like what he finds
like attractive in the bedroom and stuff
like that yeah it was like I want my
parents to listen to this and I want to
you know just so that he can be fully
and he said like he's trying to adopt I
can never never lie approach and never
[Music]
you know I've got so much respect for
people that do this that they choose to
do this like radical change
mmm it's so I find it fascinating if I'm
people I think there's so many people
exist in this safe area of I'll do a bit
of this and not that much more and guys
I came a [ __ ] yeah make it well I
what I mean and what I find almost
repeated with it is that because he's
doing it all at once yes what I said too
far what what what you know yes fair
enough the approach might work really
well for it but but his in terms of for
those of us who maybe don't want to do
all of it you don't know what his goal
isn't to create a teach as models of her
other people with you know maybe him as
good as possible yeah he's like I
definitely got that I think from our
perspective we're like we'll hang on but
we let's make one change and then
determine the result in that whereas I
think yeah he's just decide he's
deliberately shotgunning and just
thinking like mmm just yeah I did a
podcast which is now out in podcast and
with a guy called Jordan Hall who
basically worked he spends a lot of his
time thinking about how to redesign
civilizations is he he's the one one
lifehacker month thing know who is that
remember the house leader stroke
okay and that was really I really don't
know episode I think it's 40 quite young
a 38 something like that Carl cederstrom
I saw like you like really [ __ ] good
but even he said on that man anyone
who's not doing the Pomodoro Technique
he said the best life hack that you came
up with out with the entire yeah but
yeah this is easy no no how how credible
is that you hear a man who's done a year
of rotating life hack systemically he's
like Pomodoro Commodore advances man
it's free he has fun it free all the
other ones paid but that like with with
with anything like building habits for
example the truly using the Pomodoro
Technique really mastering it it's
really hard with it really hard I can do
like
a 50-percent deep Pomodoro quite easy I
can't can go hundred miles an hour I
know that is always comedy - I do
actually one-legged spin race once
really but I it's important that none of
us underestimated we can girdle the
world I mean he knows the words -
Campbell it doesn't yet so the way thing
is your car does go under policy nice
going it was no yeah and so 8 pounds 8
pounds I thought that was Kyle saying
iPod iPad definitely wasn't known to
include the cassette boy clip what's
that that's what all those references
are they yeah yeah I don't sugar thing
yeah fine video guardian will make
Island sugar appear overhead and the
Pomodoro article I'll put that in the
show notes below yeah that was a good
bloody good one of it was it the guy
came up with was a tanky CEO so
different one know it so there's a guy
called like Chris Whitfield or something
okay just tracked every proper Atlas
life including like climbing oh no that
guy that is the ikedaya yeah that was a
guy it was the guy I just coded my own
tracking software for it and locked it
all but there's another guy who was like
I was working 40 hours a week and
decided I'm just gonna deviate
Pomodoro's a day and described how he
was able to achieve the same volume of
work do you remember when deep working
remember when I got that message on
Instagram of a listener who'd been heard
us talk about the Pomodoro Technique and
it created his own spreadsheet I sent
you guys a screenshot of the spreadsheet
yeah his like manhood completely changed
my life I'm like holy [ __ ] dude I
think just relate to using pompadours
the rest of your life I think that so
that's how to ruin your life
look I'm not saying everything is a
Pomodoro I think it's purely for work
for me as soon as the the time it goes
on I tried my best to time he goes on
cold turkey email what's up max it's
like you know the noise from who wants
to be a millionaire when they start the
quiz
oh yeah yeah that's exactly yeah
Showtime
game on oh [ __ ] about because Chris
targets here yeah Jeremy Jeremy Clarkson
and they've got a new home line how he
is he got a new helpline which is ask
Jeremy Haley what he wants to even
leaner so let's assess a TV when it's
been on for a while
right Jeremy Clarkson's the new host
there's a new iPhone which is a classic
Jeremy but he's the host precisely so
that the like it's on turnaround -
Jeremy I think you go smoking early
I don't know then what was the every
time yeah
what's the she'll watch I was ill don't
know must be ITV thanks oh that reminds
me I was gonna say the thing that I
mentioned before
I didn't a lot of point UT I'm sorry
then I mentioned before about the big
thing a documentary following a
documentary following a guy who'd been
accused of a sex offense yes it's a
Louis Theroux it's on BBC iPlayer Luther
mercenary the sex offenders Oh Louie
throughs interviewing him right I wasn't
very much that I was living through just
hardly throughs mannerisms have you had
the mindset of Marc Marc born from the
big shores I wish I'd asked well let me
through
you you've seen it you see in the clip
of the Scientology trailer oh yeah I've
seen the full thing absolutely brilliant
so anything you documentary as well so
you tell him to stop and I'll tell him
to stop so the big short the guy who
produced the big short fantastic film
about the 2008 financial crisis is the
exec producer on a new Amazon Prime
documentary series with one of the
actors from Harold & Kumar Go to White
Castle and it's the guy who was a very
successful politician of like political
adviser worked in the Obama
administration it's one of the two main
actors also I spend a few things and
then it's just about money laundering
and he sounds close
it's [ __ ] MS about now available that
I was in Prime and I can't this great
beast that is the global economy wordy
title yeah so needs to work on
it's all it's kind of a bit very
American but it's [ __ ] cool so
literally the first episode is he gets
given a fake 1 million dollars and has
to work out how to launder it sounds so
good crazy
I can't wait what's up I'm so excited
he's all that direct has also done vice
this she's been in similar which is
about Dick Cheney alright yeah that's
cool that's recommend what's not so that
he is a scene where 911s just happened
Dick Cheney's played by Christian Bale
9/11 is just happened that everyone else
is in like [ __ ] uproar and Dick
Cheney's just some shorting yes out
there just thinking and then picks up
the phone and it pans out recycle no one
knew on that day why when a plane flew
into the twin towers Dick Cheney rang
his lawyer but it laid the trunk and
then it shows basically how he just like
manipulates his way like because he's
paint in a very bad light what does he
do series of ice he was the vice
president to George Bush right but no
more what does he do they just
capitalized likes it a lot of the Iraq
war a lot of the decisions made around
like when to invade and what to do with
him
what was he for how's he benefiting
financially right anyways he was CEO of
a big oil company so not not far off
not big far so like nothing far easier
just sure this yeah but it's just it's
that it's the scene where everyone's
like oh my god he's your son it's fine
not so weird because it's like is that
actually recorded but no well if it's
not in the film right but I I wouldn't
have thought so cuz it's in like the
it's an active in the film that's my
[ __ ] traumatized yeah and I did a
another podcast with the FBI's ex head
of the FBI's Behavioral Science Division
jackal Robert Drake so he is one of the
world's experts on body language think
I've seen something from him he's right
he's been around a few different a few
different podcasts but he was
unbelievable and he said he started at
the FBI about six months before 9/11 oh
my god and I asked I was like think of
the paperwork out guys
That's not me you know we were saying
last time about when someone goes into
the back of you image do all the
paperwork just slip out of your eyes
yeah it's that times a lot of time I
mean that is a lot of paperwork is he
all right
anyway gentlemen thank you very much for
coming
I'm something else to watch just
sneaking it laid on me um I often go on
Netflix
I forgot unbelievable you see it yeah
fantastic watch alphabet he's like is
Italy Sudan yeah he hit up go the game
channel sport get Chinese ball game it's
like apparently the hardest game in the
world okay bill pay deep mind so my
Google based in London it's just a bunch
of really clever people trying to make
him trying to make AI essentially and
the mark of of AI is can we get this
algorithm to beat the best go player in
the world think they managed to do in
chess but they said essentially that
because the number of permutations that
goal can have the number of different
plays that you can having go is 10 to
the 150 which is more than there are
atoms in the observable universe so
basically it was so complex hundred and
forty three billion universe if every
tear was a drop in the ocean it would so
yes and they they said they wouldn't
wouldn't be able to be done and I want I
want to buy then that surely means that
the human mind is just taking punts
rather than like the heat the mind that
someone the best go player is mostly
taking punts and it's just quite good
well no that's how do you program it how
did you can't Pro like if because if he
you can't program human to do it and you
can't program a computer to submissive
it they're trying to create intelligence
or team is just making heuristic so
their argument is their argument is that
there is some indefinable characteristic
to human intuition or whatever it might
be
which you wouldn't be able to replicate
then they do this then do you know about
alphago zero yeah that's beat half ago
100 games to zero yeah with no it was
given nothing so just itself
play locked in its own box wasn't given
the rules alphago zero started from
nothing and within four days had beaten
the game needs to go down one day yeah
yeah but so I've mentioned this on the
last catch-up episodes
Josh Clark's the end of the world if you
haven't listened to you need to go
listen to it [ __ ] unbelievable and in
that there's a fairly cleverly balanced
view of the threat of AI and it's that
something cleverest people on the planet
say that we are definitely getting
closer to very very good specific
artificial intelligence essentially in
the last thirty years we've made no
progress towards general AI yeah and
there's just there's so many very
difficult things to do like to get a
robot to be able to pick a ball up off
the ground it needs to define so many
different things
mmm what is a ball what is pick up what
are the motions that are required how do
you do it like it's impossible worry is
that you you build something specific
that becomes so intelligent that it's
like I I now need to learn this as well
and then and it lends itself to be
general do you think I mean this is why
the book super intelligence say is
separate from its own but if you promise
me this the time a man start tagging up
and said no you are basically the the
sentence that you just said there's like
there's a chapter on that like what if
question and he just goes deep down the
maths and like if we define K as the
integral of s over T and this is due to
the number of speed as a neuronal
connections that you had to what you had
to dial back the pace to back to yeah
yeah from three be the Tim Evans
you know Tim Evans on the flat earth yes
guy they interview him a few times
yep his interview with Tim Ferriss he
has them the the best like fisher-price
AI discussion I've ever heard and like
the theory of what we know how we can
live on planets or space stations like
that valent you is genuinely brilliant
so so many things let's let's recap what
people need to watch and read soon
stuff digital minimal is what if people
have read non of this stuff they're
already and for the best like common
sense like receipts work atomic habits
then they need to this one you they've
got your both of them need to watch
prescription thugs need to watch this
beast the Great Beast is the global
economy bigger stronger faster as well
bigger stronger faster
what's that the dome under the dome yeah
what's the flyer thing called something
to do with ipython that affects you'll
be able to see it's being promoted like
hell the new levy through new vocabulary
through BBC iplayer alphago yeah
anything else
big short if you've not seen the big
show if you've not seen as well yeah
unbelievable margin cool he won't seem
that her wrists of lies if you've not
seen that we've seen Wizard of lies
no brilliant it's about Bernie Madoff I
have seen it advertised the new girag
with Alex Jones four and a half hours of
unrelenting it's what stops you from
getting fully in the jury room it's just
such a commitment that will take me like
two weeks to listen to so there's this
bit to listen to it is like what what
Chris does where it's just on in the
background yeah it's a good way to
especially with that when you don't
think yeah the problem that you have
with an audiobook is you don't want to
be doing anything else while you're
listening to it it's too taxing in case
you missed some of the gold
well ridiculous fight me miss five
minutes you know art and of what's going
on yeah whereas with Alex Jones if you'd
listened to five seconds you don't know
what's going on so it's like Mike so you
might if you just never know what's
going on you find I really enjoyed the
Elon Musk on Robert Rogan
he was good I'm Tara Brown you don't
Brian was very good to hear he lucid but
Elon Musk didn't do himself any favors
in not looking like a weirdo I think
it's all part of his plan to do what to
get Tesla and SpaceX into massive
exposure
how much traffic did that interview have
well these morals are their Facebook's
he deleted it I put in there's no way
you fly rockets to Mars make electric
cars try and revolutionize all these
things but you're you're a bit of a [ __ ]
when it comes to you PR like
it's all gonna be on purpose so disease
got that kind of megalomania creates did
you see the video of his new rocket
mounted on the floor the test burn no oh
god that's the rocket that can take
people that they've just sent up isn't
it it's a new one it's just a like
prototype they just they launched one
the other day there's not that one it's
not ready yet
okay they did this thing and this sound
that this machine makes is like it just
sounds at the end of the earth like the
sort of thing that would take us to Mars
I imagine probably yes and on that note
I think we better leave gentlemen thank
you very much for coming along all of
the links to what we've linked are in
the show notes below everything that
we've brought during this podcast please
do not forget to press subscribe
Joanie's touching uses hunt he's waving
goodbye everybody
[Music]
you